The good guys that these companies weren't actually companies that they were on
our side against the corporate world.
And it turns out,
I think we've just hit this moment.
You mentioned Zuckerberg.
We,
I think we've culturally come to this moment now where,
you know,
I think symbolized by his testimony to Congress that,
uh,
those,
that,
that honeymoon period is over,
people now view him,
I think quite firmly and squarely as a CEO of a very rich company as opposed to
a guy in my club that I'm friends with WHO's on my side against the world.
You know?
And,
and that's how Google used to have that slogan,
don't do evil evil.
They still have it.
I mean,
the problem is the incentives are all wrong.
And I'm sorry,
I actually,
I was just at Ted and will they give you a sense of how far the rot has spread
here?
So I was,
I found myself at a dinner sitting next to a,
a,
a neuroscientist who thought that it was an Ezra Klein thing,
followed me around at Ted.
And it's because many people have listened to the podcast and he thought Charles
Murray should have been physically attacked at Middlebury.
This is a neuron is a neuroscientist academic,
you know what,
like a impeccable person.
Otherwise I think he was after we wound up having a fight.
Oh,
at dinner over it.
I think he was somewhat chagrined by having expressed that opinion.
But I mean that's how how emotionally hijacked people are by this issue and uh,
but it's a um,
that's incredible.
I mean it was just,
yeah,
it was other thing that's new.
This is the other thing.
It's new.
The left advocating for violence.
This is very new.
Yeah.
I mean I always felt like the,
the left was a nonviolent.
The,
the,
the whole idea behind being progressive like nonviolence was,
was a genuine aspect of that.
And free speech walls.
Two things.
Yes.
Those are two things that have been sort of stopped.
Yeah,
free speech is fine as long as you're not saying speech that I disagree with and
nonviolence.
Sure.
In less we need to use violence,
which is like,
and the people that are saying it.
Like if you watch these Antifa people like Jesus Christ,
the most incompetent,
violent people you've ever seen in your life
offends your sensibilities as an MMA guy.
Fucking,
you guys are terrible at it.
There's videos of these guys practicing.
There's videos of Antifa they had,
they got together and decided to train and prepare for violence and so they're
doing these martial arts classes.
They have people teach them like holy shit,
like at the average high school kid could fuck you guys up.
Like this is the most ridiculous thing I've ever seen in my life.
But it's almost like they're,
they realize that there's not that much danger in what they're doing and they
can kind of play with danger.
They can play with violence.
They can put the masks on there that,
you know,
they're not in Israel,
they're in check out of the Gaza Strip.
There are a bunch of counts.
There's a guy,
there's a guy who went to my old university I graduated from,
so asked before I did my masters at the LSE.
So [inaudible] has been embroiled in a strike at the moment.
It's,
the student's Union has been supporting,
uh,
professors who were on strike and it's over pension and pension rights and
refused government refusing to raise their pension rights and whatever.
And some of the students came out in strike file f students defending uh,
the professors and they put up,
they put forward a ring preventing students from attending their classes and,
and,
and a female black lecturer wanting to cross the strike lines to go in to teach
her students a white male public school educated,
very,
very middle class protester.
Far-Left physically attacked her,
he physically attacked a female black professor.
So gone is suddenly gone.
Is The white privilege gone?
Is the male attacking a female,
you know,
gone is all of that non violence in the name of ideology.
He legitimized and allowed himself to attack a black female,
by the way.
Oh.
And she was also Muslim,
so she was,
she went to the prep.
You would've had the right [inaudible] in our interview.
She said,
I'm a black Muslim female and is my kid is just a tie for wanting to teach.
My class is crazy.
This is crazy.
It's a crazy world we're in,
man.
This is.